et elle est avec nous je vous le dis et
jean-luc va danser un peu jauni chaîne
et quand vous l'êtes vous êtes fou
d'elle la bûche fou d'elle j'ai bien
l'impression d'une rexie pente est raide
avec nous c'est la reine du to work
applaudissements n'ont droit ni à tes
yeux cernés gay de stars
ce week-end et aux aidants
pour l'élan
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sa merci alors la première question
posée c'est oui c'est à quel sujet bravo
en tout cas c'était le titre est très
bon et c'est la reine du thouet rck
j'aimerais qu'on fait voici un tour
qu'avec jean luc lemoine parce qu'il n'a
il ne dort jamais jean-luc je vous ai
amené la plus belle rose oui oui oui
allez va bien jean luc hallé 6
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ah bon
jean luc labrecque
cherry est ce qu'on peut pas voir moi ce
que j'aimerais c'est que le welsh est
pas si matthew d'accord avec moi
j'aimerais qu'on ait agathe et nora qui
vont feindre un touareg avec lexie
[Applaudissements]
alexis
voilà
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
wedia
merci entre aller vers temps pour calmer
tout le monde voudra isabelle
[Applaudissements]
allez-y
encore
ah ah
m
[Applaudissements]
merci à chéri joel bien merci à l'équipe
on taira le nom
est disponible sur toutes les
plateformes de téléchargement légal et
chantonner le tout à part
[Applaudissements]